[Music]
i'm excited for fans to get to see
this giant four hour movie that's
completely
singular to their investment if you
followed the first two movies
this movie really kind of takes you into
a completely immersive
scope and scale
[Music]
the fan community has sort of risen up
demanding
this version well because of the promise
i've made them
over the course of the two other movies
it has
created this movement that said
we need to know how it ends
[Music]
okay so because this will be once you do
this you do i beam them
you're going to have your run in with
cyborg where you
zack he's got such an incredible
brain for the visual he has everything
planned out in his head before we get
there it's remarkable to be a part of
everything
that we work in we're stepping into his
drawings so you're like can i see this
scene
before we make it and he has beautiful
drawings
you know they're very good about making
sure that we get exactly what it is that
they've envisioned
you know so you know the way they set up
all these shots it's so specific
and so well thought out all i have to do
is just step in
and breathe
i like zack and he's got a lot of
enthusiasm and he's got this boyish kind
of energy where he's just
psyched to be at work every day and i
think you need that to get through
a herculean effort like these movies
ready ready okay let's go
when i'm on set and we're shooting it's
a fun atmosphere for me
i mean i don't want to say it's a
playground but it is a bit
[Music]
it was just so nice and there was never
a dull moment
on set we're always talking or making
each other laugh
it was just awesome
yeah i want to be
like excited there's a lot of beautiful
traits that i will take on
more than anyone i've ever worked with
don't tell him that but he's all right
he's all right
you know just over the course of making
these sort of epic movies you know you
get
closer to the actors i do count them all
as friends
and i think with all of these guys sort
of cast them
in their alter ego first and model that
to who they are as people
that allows the character because it's
grounded
it allows you to accept the superhero
version in a much
easier way
in this movie in justice league because
there's no time restraint on the film
it does give us an opportunity to really
see everyone
fulfill their arc within the context of
the movie the emotional journey is there
it's been really fun to put the original
steppenwolf back in the movie
you know he's quite realized character
you know he has struggles
he has history we understand his
relationship to darkseid and assad and
you get it why he's doing what he's
doing
he will see my worth again
[Music]
and then being able to shoot an
additional scene for justice league
and it was fun to do and it's fun to get
ben back in the cowl
he looks as good as ever in that cowl i
was like we never stopped
you still think it was a good idea
bringing him along
what do you think
in any endeavor to be supported is an
incredible thing
you know especially supported by this
incredible fan base
they've really taken the movie to heart
and so there is something really
satisfying and fun for me bringing these
amazing fans a movie that they wanted to
see
there's an attack coming it's already
here
this really blows out to a much larger
mythological
version of the movie these epic set
pieces one after another
i bring together a team people with
special abilities
really epic gods fighting god's scale so
that's what i'm excited for fans to get
to see
they'll fall
they will join you in the sun cup
you